عوده الان الى موضوع امدادات السلاح
الاوروبيه لاوكرانيا التهيمن اربع دول على
خريطه الصناعه العسكريه في اوروبا هي
فرنسا المانيا وبريطانيا وايطاليا وتعتبر
مبيعات الاسلحه احدى اهم مصادر الدخل في
تلك البلدان تحتل فرنسا طبعا المرتبه
الثالثه عالميا في تصدير السلاح بنحو احد
10% هي اول بلد يرسل اسلحه ثقيله الى
اوكرانيا من دبابات متراس ايمكس
ار سي اما المانيا فهي خامس مصدر للاسلحه
عالميه
سعاد دبابات ليوبارد التي تتردد برلين في
تزويد كيفها عماد الصناعه العسكريه
المانيا
اما الصناعات العسكريه البريطانيه ايضا
تحظى بمكانه مهمه اوروبيا وعالميا وتعد
دبابه تشالنجر تحديدا فخر هذه الصناعه
وتستعد لندن لارسال اربعه عشر دبابات منها
الى اوكرانيا
طبعا مثل كل القطاعات فقد تاثرت
الصناعه العسكريه الاوروبيه بالحرب على
اوكرانيا وقررت معظم البلدان زياده
الانفاق العسكري تحسبا للاسوا ولمواكبه
احتياجات كيف
قررت المانيا تخصيص 100 مليار يورو اضافيه
للجيش مع زياده المستدامه في الميزانيه
العسكريه بنسبه اثنين في المئه من الناتج
المحلي الالماني وهذا رقم
ضخم جدا بريطانيا اعلنت زياده في
الميزانيه الدفاع بنحو مليار
و400 ب 400 مليون جنيه استرليني لتصبح 50
مليار جنيه خلال السنه الماليه 2023 2004
فرنسا قررت في مارس الماضي تخصيص اكثر من
2% من نتائجها المحليه الاجمالي للانفاق
العسكري
اجمالا زاد الانفاق العسكري الاوربي بنسبه
19 في المئه خلال العام الماضي مدفوعا
بالحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
سنناقش هذا الموضوع
في بريطانيا الدكتور بيتر روبرتس كبير
الخبراء في المعهد الملكي للشؤون الدفاعيه
والامنيه اهلا وسهلا بك همم
في الحصاد وابدا معك بهذه المظله العسكريه
الامريكيه التي استفادت منها اوروبا
للسنوات هل الحرب الاوكرانيه
ايقظت اوروبا على ضروره عدم الاعتماد على
هذه المظله
لن تدوم للابد بالنسبه لهم
الاوروبينا بدؤوا كما اشارتم الى زياده
الانفاق العسكري القضيه هي حقيقه لا يمكن
تعزيز النظام الدفاعي وزياده الرفاق عليه
في حين انه منظر ثمانيات اهملوه ولم
يعتنوا به فاضطروا الى شراء المعدات
العسكريه من امريكا واماكن اخرى هذه مشكله
حقيقيه وهي اقناع
القاده الاوروبيين والساس الاوروبيين الان
ينفقوا بنفسه الامد البعيد هناك كثير من
التطورات في الفضاء في المعلومات وكل هذا
كل هذا التطور لم لم حقيقه لم يتم وبقيت
حاجات الحرب التقليديه وبرصت قضيه اوك على
السطح ربما ليس اكثر من اسبوعين قبل الحرب
نفسها وهذا اثار صدمه في اوروبا
ان ترامب كان اول من نادى على الاوروبيين
همم لكي يستيقظوا طلبهم بضروره ايقاف
الاعتماد على الامريكيين وضروره الاعتماد
على انفسهم وزياده وان ينفقوا فعلا بدل ان
يعتمد على الولايات المتحده
في الحقيقه نعم الامر يعود حتى الى ما قبل
ذلك خلال الرئيس ازنور والله اذا كان يدعو
الاوروبيين الى انفاق المزيد ولا الالتزام
بحصته من الانفاق لكنهم لم يفعله الرئيس
ترامب ثم فعل له حقيقه كان التعبير عن هذا
الموقف بشكل اكثر وضوحا بصوت اعلى من خلال
الحديث
المستقبليه عليهم حتى في 2011 عندما قررت
فرنسا بريطانيا انهما ارادتها قصف
ليبيا في خلال يومين نصرت منهما الذخائر
فقط اريد ان اسال سؤال سريع ايضا فيما
يتعلق بالخلافات
اوروبيه لدرجه الدعم ودرجه
السلاح والان ولكن الخلاف داخل كل دوله
نفسها الى اي حد يلعب دور في ايضا تغيير
السياسه
العسكريه
سياسه الانفاق العسكري
لان كل بلد من هذه البلدان يعاني ويكابد
داخليا في تقرير ماذا يريده الناس والشعب
وكيف يقرر الساسه التعامل مع ذلك ومع
تلبيه احتياجاته اوكرانيا في اداره الوقت
هذا السبب
يواجه اساس صعوبه في اقناع راي العام داخل
البلاد وتربيه الاحتياجات الدفاعي وكما
اشارتهم هناك مواقف متباينه حول كم من
الدعم المال الذي يجب ان ينفق الالمان هم
الاكثر تلقوا في هذا المكان
لشؤون الدفاعيه والامنيه شكرا جزيلا